All right.
Wonderful.
That picture was amazing.
Yeah.
Sleep.
Guys are,
>> how are you, bud?
Just check your mic.
Also
trying to
do that.
>> I mean
all of a sudden overnight
Yeah, I get it.
Hello. Hello.
>> Hi everyone.
Welcome to the table.
Welcome to the time change.
Uh my name is Karen Miner. My pronouns
are she, her, and I am so glad you're
here with us tonight. The ones who are
on time, let's just be clear about that.
Good job, Gold Star, for all of you. Um
I just have a few announcements. Uh
things that are coming up, things to
look forward to.
And pardon me with my phone up here. I
don't want to miss anything. We have
quite a few announcements. Um, the first
one is our Sunday Unbound.
Sunday Unbound basically is where we
take Sundays, same time, five o'clock,
but we do something totally different.
We don't do church like this. We are not
in the sanctuary. We don't do our usual
routine. Uh, we're just pushing out what
church is, what a church community is,
what a church community does. And we're
taking things beyond the walls. So, we
have two of those Sunday Unbounds coming
up. The next one is next Sunday, one
week from tonight at 5:00 PM. We're
going to be meeting in the Family Life
Center, which is the building right
behind this one. And for that one, we
are going to be focusing on what it
means to be a community. We will also be
having a potluck because everything's
better with food. So, if you would like
to uh participate in that, I hope you'll
all be there. Uh, you're welcome to
bring something for the potluck. You'll
just scan the code up on the screens.
And I want to get you thinking about the
Sunday Unbound after
the next one. It will be on May 31st.
So, it's still a ways out, but what
we're going to do is we are going to
head out of the building to serve those
in our community. So, we're currently
soliciting suggestions from all of you.
Uh, think about a neighbor, maybe a a
member of the church or a family or
someone that can use um a helping hand.
It might be uh a grocery delivery. It
could be yard work. It could be minor
repairs on their home. Um, so if you
scan the QR code, there will be a form
there where you can nominate someone.
and I can't think of of anything better
but to be a community that helps one
another. Um, so scan the QR code, check
that out, and uh if you could do that by
March 28th, that would be great. The
organizing team will review all
nominations and figure out the ones that
we can be accomp that we think can be
accomplished. So, we're hoping to do
more than one. So, um, be sure to, uh,
to sign up for that. Next, we are coming
into Holy Week. I cannot believe we're
here already. So, there are three
opportunities to participate in Holy
Week. And, uh, the first one is going to
be Palm Sunday. That's on March 29th. It
will be a very special service. It's
always really fun and everybody gets
involved in it. Uh, so be there for
that. And then uh secondly, Good Friday.
We're going to be attending Saxi First's
Good Friday service. That's the church
that we rent from here. And so we like
to join together with them and be a part
of their Good Friday service. Uh it's a
canata, so it will mostly be music
centered, the cross of Christ. And then
all of that leads up to our Easter
service. And again, because we rent
space, a Sunday morning on Easter gets
really tricky.
So, we like to do our Easter service the
night before, Saturday night. So, that's
what we'll be doing on April 4th and
same time, right? 5:00 pm for that 5:00
p.m. And we'll also be uh in addition to
the service, we'll enjoy a meal together
and me the food will be provided. So,
you don't have to bring anything, just
show up and uh we will celebrate Easter
together. Uh because we're celebrating
Easter the day before, we will not have
our regular service here on Sunday,
April 5th. So that's a lot. Scan the QR
code. It will give you everything you
need to know. All right. The candles
behind me serve as a reminder of the
presence of the Holy Spirit. Always with
us, always around us.
Let's prepare our hearts to worship.
Close
your eyes.
Take a deep breath in
and out.
One more time. Breathe in.
Breathe out.
Be here now.
Set aside your day. Set aside the week
ahead.
remembering God as the source
of our hope, our love, our peace, and
our strength.
Especially in trying times like these
when there's
war,
when there are rights being trampled.
God, we remember that you are our source
that we can hold with both hands
worry and faith
and knowing that
your hope does not disappoint.
So now we exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry and productivity.
And we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
Sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and
adoration.
A place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
Thank you, Karen. If you guys would
stand with us, we're going to get
started with some music tonight. And I'm
just reminded of um when we're together
like this, what a gift it is that we are
all showing up to hold this space. Um
it's really a gift. our presence um and
what it does in each other. Whenever we
see somebody else that's coming into
this space openhearted and ready to
offer who they are um and being here as
a whole person, whatever's gone on in
the week before you and whatever is
going to happen this next week, in this
moment, we share it together and we hold
it before God and ask him to meet with
us here in our worship. So, you guys
sing out. Um, let your voices find space
in the room if you if you have the
courage to do so. Your whole body is a
part of this experience. Um, so I just
invite you into it with us.
We're going to sing Be
My Soul.
Be still know that my God is here.
Be still my soul.
Be still and know that my God is here.
All that I need to know is this. You are
a good God. The maker of heaven calls me
heaven. You are a good God. and his
heart beats into my chest. You are a
good
all that I have to do is raise his word.
I won't be afraid.
I won't be afraid. My God is here.
He will make a way. He will make a way.
He will make a way. My God is here. All
that I need to know is this. You are a
good God. The maker of heaven. Closing
hands. You are a good God. And your
heart beats in my chest. You are a good
God. All that I have to do is
good.
You gave me your eyes. You gave me your
heart. Your spirit flows through my
veins. You gave me your eyes. You gave
me your heart. Your spirit flows through
my veins. You give me your eyes. You
give me your heart. Your spirit flows
through my veins. You give me your eyes.
You give me your heart. Your spirit
flows through my veins. You gave me your
eyes. You gave me your heart. You had a
plan right from the start. And I know
who I am cuz I know who you are. You are
a good God. All that I need to know is
this.
The maker of heaven calls me.
All that I need to know is this. You are
a good God. The maker of heaven calls me
his. You are a good God.
>> When your heart beats in my chest, you
are a good God. All that I have to do is
reward.
>> You're a good God. You are a good God.
You are a good God. You are a good God.
You are a good God.
>> All right. Our kids are dismissed to go
to their classes and their teachers are
going to meet them right over here by
the double doors.
Thank you guys for singing with us.
And as they exit the room, we're going
to transition to what we call prayers of
the people, which is a tradition
throughout Christian history that we're
going to join in with tonight. Um, you
can read along on the screens and the
parts that are in red, we will read out
loud together. And then I invite you in
the middle of the prayer to offer up
whatever it is that you're carrying into
this space tonight. You could speak out
a name or a situation that's heavy on
your heart. And we want to hold that up
before Christ, believing he's here with
us.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us, and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So, we lift
these names and situations up to you.
Johnny,
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence.
Amen.
and we've been hiding
in the shadows,
lost and afraid of you.
We've been wandering
in the darkness.
But if we only knew,
we are known and loved.
Known in love. We are known in love by
you.
You've been waiting
to show us mercy.
Your presence is our home.
>> We're your children.
Love forever.
Now every fear is gone.
We are known in love.
Known in love. We are known in love by
you.
We are known in love.
Known in love. We are known in love by
you.
There is no fear
anymore
cuz all that's left is mercy.
There is no fear
in your love
cuz you're the God of mercy.
There is no fear
anymore
cuz all that's left is mercy.
There is no fear
in your love
in your love.
We are known and loved.
Known and loved. We are known in love by
you.
We are known in love.
Known in love. We are known in love by
you.
Here
is where I lay it down. every burden,
every crown. This is my surrender.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay it down. Every lie
and every doubt. This is my surrender.
And I will make room for you.
to do whatever you want to,
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
Here is where I lay it down. Every
burden, every crown. This is my
surrender.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay it down. Every lie
and every doubt. This is my surrender.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to.
To do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to.
To do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to. Oh.
Ooh.
So shake up the ground of all my
tradition. Break down the walls of all
my religion. Your way is better.
Your way is better.
Shake up the ground of all my tradition.
Break down the walls of all my religion.
And your way is better.
Your way is better.
Shake up the ground of all my tradition.
Break down the walls of all my religion.
Your way is better.
Shake out the ground to pull my
tradition. Break down the walls for my
religion. Your way is better.
Your way is better.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to.
And I will make room for you
to do whatever you want to
>> to do whatever you want to. You want to
Here
is where I
chasing.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay it down. You are all
I'm chasing now. This is my surrender.
This is my surrender.
God, help us in the areas where we want
to hang on to things that we've known in
the past, but that are keeping us tied
up,
enslaved to something that's not from
you.
God, would you help us to let go of
things
that are in our way of becoming more
like Jesus?
Maybe it's our past.
Maybe it's our flaws, our failures, the
mistakes that we've made that we can't
let go of.
My control, God,
my manipulation,
my fears.
God, sometimes it's our busyiness, that
desire to stay going, to keep running
when we need to be quiet, when we need
to be still.
Or sometimes it's the apathy.
God, whatever is in our way tonight,
would you help us to let it go
and would we only pick up the things
that are from you,
the ways of Jesus,
the ways that steer us towards love,
light,
freedom,
forgiveness,
hope, hope.
God, would we be open to your work,
to your new life?
And God, help us to let go of the old,
to be a new creation each day,
made by a loving God.
who's known and loved by you.
A people, a community, a church that is
known and loved by you.
Yeah. God, keep doing your work in us.
It's in your name that we pray. Amen.
Thank you guys for worshiping with us.
If you'd turn to the people on your
right and left and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you." And then Brett will
start our message.
Grace and peace and uh welcome welcome
to the table. So glad uh that you all
are with us and uh yeah just it's good
to be together be in this space and as
always that includes those join us
online. You're not forgotten. Glad you
could be with us as well and especially
anyone here tonight who is new. If this
is your first time or your first time in
a long time we're really really glad
that you're you know here among us and
um yeah participating. So, um the uh
let's see, we're in the the third Sunday
of Lent and uh this is a basically a
time of um kind of heart and mind
preparation as we approach like Good
Friday, that's the day of the cross, and
then on to Easter. And um so we're kind
of we're following what's called the
church lectionary, kind of the
prescribed reading. So the sermons are a
little bit kind of um jumping around,
but it's because we're we're always just
following the the kind of one of the
scriptures, at least that was assigned
for the week. And so, um, the title of
my message this week is Embrace the
Unknowing. Embrace the unknowing. And
our reading is from the Gospel of John,
uh, chapter 9:es 1-41.
And, uh, it's lengthy. It's a lengthy
um, story, but it is very interesting.
So, I'm going to go ahead and um, read
through it and uh, and then we'll kind
of unpack some of the maybe implications
for where we're going with this. So it
says this, "As he went along, he saw a
man blind from birth. And his disciples
asked him,"Rabbi, who sinned, "This man
or his parents that he was born blind?"
We're already off to a great start. You
know, it's like, "Okay, guys, what are
we doing here? Neither this man nor his
parents sinned," said Jesus. "But this
happens that the works of God might be
displayed in him. As long as it is day,
we must do the works of him who sent me.
Night is coming when no one can work.
While I'm in the world, I'm the light of
the world. After saying this, he spit on
the ground, made some mud with the
saliva, and put it on the man's eyes.
Go, he told him, "Wash in the pool of
Siloam." That word means scent. So the
man went and washed and came home
seeing. I'm just I'm kind of imagining
it from his perspective like, "Oh my
god, like what a moment," you know? I
mean, it's so easy. we get become very
familiar with these stories and it's
kind like oh yes and the man he went and
washed and he was he could see again you
know and it's like oh like just kind of
enter into his mind you know in that
moment just like you know decades he's
waited for that like just incredible his
neighbors and those who had formerly
seen him begging asked isn't this the
same man who used to sit and beg some
claimed that he was others said no no no
he only he only looks like him but he
himself insisted I am the man how then
were your eyes open they asked he
replied the man they called Jesus, made
some mud and put it on my eyes. He told
me to go to Saleom and wash. So I went
and washed and then I could see. Where
is this man? They asked him. I don't
know, he said. They brought to the
Pharisees the man who had been blind.
Now the day on which Jesus had made the
mud and opened the man's eyes was a
Sabbath. This becomes kind of
controversial because um according to
kind of some traditions that was like
work. You know, Jesus was he was
working. So you're working on the
Sabbath. And this was like become a
major dispute between Jesus and some of
the religious leaders of that of that
day. Therefore, the Pharisees also asked
him how he had received his sight. He
put mud on my eyes, the man replied. And
I washed and now I see. I wonder, it's
interesting he says he put mud on my
eyes. Not like he made mud and then put
it on my, you know, he doesn't go into
details. I wonder if he's trying to kind
of get out of help kind of save Jesus'
reputation here of like because that
would be the work thing. You're making
the mud to do the thing. You know what I
mean? So anyway, it's just interesting.
The man replied, "I washed and now I
see." Some of the Pharisees said, "This
man is not from God, for he does not
keep the Sabbath." But others asked,
"How can a sinner perform such signs?"
So they were divided. Then they turned
again to the blind man. What have you to
say about him? It was your eyes he
opened. The man replied, "He is a
prophet." They still did not believe
that he had been blind and had received
his sight until they sent for the man's
parents. "Is this your son?" they asked.
Is this the one you say was born blind?
How is it that now he can see? We know
he is our son, the parents answered. And
we know he was born blind. But how he
can see now or who opened his eyes? We
don't know. Ask him. He's of age. He'll
speak for himself. His parents said this
because they were afraid of the Galilean
leaders who already had decided that
anyone who acknowledged that Jesus was
the Messiah would be put out of the
synagogue. That was why his parents had
said, "He's of age. Ask him." A second
time they summoned the man who had been
blind. Give glory to God by telling the
truth. They said, "We know this man's a
sinner." He replied, "Whether he's a
sinner or not, I don't know. One thing I
do know, I was blind, but now I see."
It's a great response. Then they asked
him, "What did he do to you? H how did
he open your eyes?" He answered, "I've
told you already and you did not listen.
Why do you want to hear it again? Do you
want to become his disciples, too? Then
they hurled insults at him. They said,
"You're this fellow's disciple? We're
disciples of Moses. We know that God
spoke to Moses. As for this fellow, we
don't even know where he comes from."
The man answered, "Well, now that's
remarkable. You don't know where he
comes from. And yet, he opened my eyes."
We know that God does not listen to
sinners. He listens to the godly person
who does his will. Nobody's ever heard
of opening the eyes of a man born blind.
If this man were not from God, he could
do nothing. To this they replied, "You
were steeped in sin at birth. How dare
you lecture us
and they threw him out."
Jesus heard that they had thrown him out
and when he found him, he said, "Do you
believe in the Son of Man?" "Who is he,
sir?" the man asked. "Tell me so that I
may believe in him." Jesus said, "You
have seen, you have now seen him. In
fact, he is the one speaking with you.
Then the man said, 'Lord, I believe. And
he worshiped him.
Jesus said, "For judgment I have come
into this world so that the blind will
see
and those who see
will become blind."
Some Pharisees who were with him heard
him say this and asked like they're
getting, you know, they're picking up
what he's putting down. You know what?
Are we blind too? Jesus said, "If you
were blind, you would not be guilty of
sin. But now that you claim you can see,
your guilt remains."
You can see why I wanted to read the
whole thing. It's a powerful it's a
powerful powerful story. One of the the
the kind of key motifs like this
recurring theme that happens all
throughout the gospels Matthew, Mark,
Luke, John is uh this idea
that well and is very prevalent in this
story that that that the kind of
uneducated, the unlearned, the poor,
um
those kind of on the margins and edges
of society like it's they basically
they're the ones in each of the gospel
stories who they come to they they see
or come to see.
Um whereas it's the powerful, the
religious leaders, the educated,
especially the religiously educated
who you would think they're the ones I
could see, you know what I mean? But
then they're always the ones who remain
blind, you know? So in essence, what is
and what's that metaphor of like blind
and seeing and all that? Well, it's this
kind of this idea of they they they
remain unable to perceive Christ. Like
of course they can see him, you know
what I mean? But they don't they don't
get it.
They don't get it. They they see without
seeing, so to speak. They hear without
hearing. You know, it's like they hear
the words, they don't get it. You know,
I mean, they see the man, they don't get
him.
While the unlearned, the poor, you and
so on, they're the ones who or in this
story, the blind becomes the one who
sees. You know, it's it becomes this
kind of parable. So, it's this picture
of um what it means to understand
Christ. Now, some of what's going to
follow kind of in this message today is
uh well, it may sound kind of anti- you
know, intellectual and um that's not I
don't want to kind of advoc advocate for
that. I do think, you know, reading
reading is great. Y'all know me. I'm a
reader of books. I freaking love books.
So nerdy. Um it's wonderful. And I
think, you know, spiritual reading and
learning is wonderful, you know, even
reading spiritual books and theology and
it's great. Uh, and I think kind of
we've hopefully all had those moments,
you know, you ever just had like the
right book at the right time or like the
right uh, it can even be maybe even like
a book of the Bible or um, or a right
verse, you know, or an an insight. Uh,
and it could be kind of Christian
religious or it could be something, you
know, but you just you've had those
moments, you know, where sometimes it's
like a connection thing, you know, where
like an author is like, you know, you
know this and you know this, but have
you ever seen how they connect? You know
what I And it's this kind of like it's
like this the you had the aha moment,
you know what I mean? The the the moment
of clarity or have you had that that
moment where you're like taking
something in and all of a sudden like
people use this often with scripture but
it can be other books too where they'll
say the words did what they jumped off
the page at me. Have you had this this
moment? Or maybe another way to put it
is like I read the thing and it was like
I just knew this is true. Have you had
that kind of moment?
A few of you at least a few. Yeah. You
know, so like that. So that's where I
think that's the beauty of reading study
the int and even what we do here like
you know preaching and stuff and you all
listening and you know that's like a
kind of an intellectual kind of thing
but that's kind of what we're hoping for
is some of those you know kind of
moments of like wow you know where the
the truth kind of breaks in so that's
wonderful you know I mean that's
important can be really key for our
journey uh but what I think this story
shows is there's also a there is a well
the intellect you know the the kind of
analyzing rational mind it's trixy you
know what I mean like it it kind of uh
it gets well there's a kind of danger to
it um particularly in the spiritual life
when it comes to the things of God
because it's it's almost like um it's
almost like there becomes this buffer
between like me and God like in the
sense of um it's like all of my ideas
and
uh theories and words and expectations
and I don't know it's like this uh
becomes this kind of buffer this thing
you know it's like there's and in
essence there's a difference between God
and all of my ideas
about God does that make sense like
there's a I mean even you can even take
something practical ical like um I don't
know like birds you know there's a
difference between like an actual bird
and reading books about birds
you know what I mean and you're like I
study birds and I analyze birds and I'm
I you know and but at some point you
kind of like oh the words and ideas
about birds that's wonderful but like
you need to like go actually engage with
the birds you know like this is does
that make sense and that's kind of you
can see where um that plays out um with
us and God. It's it's almost like um all
of our kind of ideas and stories and
learnings and theology and all it
becomes this um it's almost like uh I
don't know almost kind of an identity in
ways you know an identity that we've
kind of built this conceptual framework
in our mind um where we kind of tell
ourselves a story you know this is who I
am and this is what I believe and this
is what has to be true and if it's not
true well then my whole world will come
crashing down, you know, and this is why
we kind of, you know, we start clinging
to our like ideas and our prejudices and
preconceptions and frameworks and, you
know, we we kind of death grip them. Um
because
it's uh we just have this feeling of you
know, if we give them up like um we'll
fall to pieces, you know, because
there's this sort of fusion in essence
between like beliefs and identity. be if
I had to put it in two words it would be
beliefs identity like for example this
is why um people very rarely change
their politics you ever noticed this
where like and people when they do it's
sort of cataclysmic you know it's like a
big deal you know um it's interesting
why is that it's because of what I'm
talking about it's it's not just about
ideas like oh I used to believe some
things and then I realized like ah that
was kind of off and so then I changed
it's never that crazy. You know what I
mean? It's like, well, I believe some
things and I believe some things about
me and others and the world and like
this is how it is.
And then when that shifted, oh my gosh,
you know what I mean? Like it was it was
a a big big deal because it's about
identities, right? It's this whole story
um about myself in the world. And um so
in light of that, can you kind of see a
little bit of the danger of the the
intellect and why it would be that in
the gospels, church leaders, pastors,
theologians
are always the last to get it,
which is sort of disturbing to me. Uh
because you know why I mean just to be
frank you know why is it that it's
likely me who will be last into the
kingdom in the age to come you know like
I should be first I'm the leader you
know whatever uh why is that? Well
because it's so easy to get so doubled
down on all my ideas
about God.
uh Thomas Aquinus was uh one of the just
absolute like giants of uh really
western theology. He had a huge
influence on like Roman Catholicism and
but even no matter your tradition like
if you want to be a theologian you have
to read Dumbquin that's just like no
matter your tradition like it's he's
just uh huge and uh I mean even people
who don't like his ideas still um agree
he was a genius you know he like fused
kind of arisatilian like Aristotle and
Christianity and made sense of it was
like he's freaking brilliant um but
suddenly on December 6 in the year 1273
he stopped writing
like he just he just stopped. His friend
uh Reginald urged him to uh continue,
you know, uh but Thomas was just like,
"I can't." He just refused.
And um
for days, this went on actually for days
and weeks like Reginald just kind of
begging him like, "Thomas, you got to
resume your work." In fact, he was
almost done with his famous uh uh suma
suma theologia, this like big old
systematic theology. And like you
imagine being like 90% through a book,
like you're almost there, multiple
volumes. And he's like, I'm done. I
can't I can't write anything else.
Finally, he convinced uh his friend
Reginald convinced Thomas like tell like
tell me what is going on. And uh he said
this. He said, "I adjure you by the
living almighty God and by the faith you
have in our order and by charity that
you strictly promise me you'll never
reveal in my lifetime what I tell you.
Everything I have written seems like
straw to me compared to those things
that I have seen and have been revealed
to me."
We don't know like exactly what
happened, but the details some of the
details that came out later were
apparently some weeks before he'd been
celebrating mass and uh on the feast of
St. Nicholas and he had some sort of
vision of God or something and I mean it
just completely
upended him. It just like
it just it just wrecked him. And in
fact, after that day, he never wrote
another word.
They're just done.
Why?
It's what we have to get. Words can
never do God justice. You don't You
can't pin God down,
you know, with with your ideas. my
ideas.
And I think this is why the mystics, you
know, although they were often
theologically educated and appreciated
that, you know, life of the mind and
such. Um, so either the Christian
mystics, they're always kind of nudging
us though, um, into a kind of, um, well,
I'll say not into a kind of intellectual
confidence, you know, a kind of like dog
like mystics are rarely dogmatists.
Very rare. like they're usually very
open-handed
and uh
they they want us to be in this place of
kind of admitting. It's hard for me to
say. I don't know.
I don't know. Say that with me. I don't
know. It's nice. Try it again. I don't
know.
Is that hard to say? I don't know. We
don't say that a lot. You know what I
mean? Uh in life. And you look out into
the world today,
everyone knows.
Doesn't everyone everyone knows
everything.
Everyone's certain. In fact, just listen
to the Pharisees in our passage today.
We know this man is a sinner.
We know that God spoke to Moses. We know
God does not listen to sinners. We know.
We know. We've got it. Oh, we got it all
figured out, right? This is the This is
the fundamentalist kind of impulse, you
know, this kind of grasping for like
control and certainty.
You know, I know. And then it becomes
kind of communal. You know what I mean?
Like churches get really bought into
this where it's like not only do I know,
but we know. We know. Don't we? We know.
But you know those people, they don't
know. They don't know. But we know.
know, I mean, it's this like it's sort
of individual ego. It's collective each
time. Yeah, we know. You know,
and uh and don't you dare imply that we
don't know because that fills us with so
much anxiety and fear. We can't handle
that. We're going to freak out and we're
just going to double down that we know,
you know.
Oh, Milanta. Contrast that with the uh
with the blind man in the story.
Where is this man? And they asked him,
"I don't know." He said, "Whether he's a
sinner or not, I don't know.
One thing I do know, I was blind, but
now I see."
And in the whole story, that's about the
only thing he knows. You know, it's like
anything with his direct experience. I
was blind, but now I see. He talks with
Jesus, has that resonance of truth
and worships, you know, has this moment
of kind of all in one, but it's all kind
of very direct. You know what I mean?
Like notice in his interactions with the
religious leaders, like he just wasn't
going to engage with them. Like no
arguing, no defending,
nothing. He's just like, I don't know.
He didn't know.
But uh the religious leaders, well, they
know it all.
So, what does this kind of mean for us?
I I would maybe frame it like this. Um
it's the million things we know
that blind us to the truth,
which is interesting. You know, we I
think we tend to think it's our it's a
gap. It's the the lack of what I don't
know, you know, meaning that's what's
holding me back, you know, but this is
the trick. Well, yes, there's truth in
that, but just as much of a problem is
all of the things that we supposedly
know. You know what I mean? All the
things we're kind of rigid and double
down on that actually prevents us um
from really uh
having that taste of God at that
relational level. Another way to put it
is to to receive God demands a kind of
heart and mind posture of unknowing,
humility, and openness.
And this is why I you all hear me all
the time talking about um various
spiritual practices and such. And I'm
particularly interested in ones that
really get us into that heart and mind
posture of I don't know, a kind of
openness. You know, this is why I love
uh a prayer uh without words, a prayer
of silence. I think it's so powerful
because it's what is that? It's almost
like every time we um kind of sit in
that kind of posture, you know, just
kind of enter into a a quiet place, it's
sort of like we're saying, you know, not
with words, but with our whole being, I
don't know.
I don't know. I don't know what I need.
I don't know what you need. I Isn't that
interesting? Like, I don't know how to
fix you.
And you don't know how to fix me. And I
don't I don't know how to fix the world.
I don't know. But but I trust I trust
that in this radical openness, I trust
that deep calls to deep as the psalmist
says that God I trust that you are
making me and all things new.
Right? Right? And then the point is to
then take that same kind of heart and
mind posture into life. I had a uh a
seminary professor, wonderful, and I
remember at one class very memorably, he
held up his Bible and he said, "I've
been reading this for 50 years, and the
more I read, the less I understand."
Of course, it's supposed to be reversed.
You're like, "No, that's not what we
want to hear from you, seminary
professor. you understand it all. And we
as the students, we can't wait till we
too can understand it all. You know, no,
no, no, no. And you, you know, those of
us all are getting along in years, the
longer you live, it's true, right? The
less you know, you know what I mean?
Like, and you're younger, you're like,
I'm pretty confident I've got it, or at
the very least, I'm going to have it
very soon, you know, certainly by 35,
you know, or whatever. Um, and it's
like, no, no.
The further I journey into God, the less
I know,
the less certainty I have, you know what
I mean? But in the sense of deep calls
to deep, the more I trust.
That's true. The more peace I have,
that's true. the more faith I have in
this reality that my words, my fragile
failing words are always falling short,
you know, but the more faith I have that
uh God is and loves and is calling us
and all things forward that I I resonate
with, right? But but it's that it's at
that deeper level, you know? I mean,
it's not the kind of rational perceiving
mind where I can explain it all, you
know? But it's in a it's a kind of
deeper
knowing, you know,
and uh you know, I think in in a lot of
ways to kind of close this out, I think
like this is what the season of Lent is
all about. You know, it's not about
adding a bunch of things to myself.
Some of you are fasting in this season,
you know, various things. What's that
about? It's a stripping away. It's a
stripping away. It's an it's an
emptying.
And so here's your practice this week. I
want to invite you to relax into the not
knowing. The word relax there is very
key because it's very easy when you get
into this not knowing like that you get
rigid and you know I mean kind of start
thrashing about like you know panicky
anxiety. So it's that's the that's the
trick. Relax into it. relax into the
relax into the not knowing and just know
the harder it is for you the more you
need it and the more it's working. Does
that make sense? You know what I mean?
We often think I'm doing so badly at it
and it's like well yeah that means like
this is the perfect medicine you know
this is wonderful.
relax into the not knowing and just
start to notice too, you know, notice
all those times when the mind is it's
grasping for certainty. Certainty around
religion and theology and politics and
work and family and the kids and
yourself and the future and the world,
you know, relax in the not knowing. Be
like the blind man who did not know a
thing,
but suddenly from that place he could
see. Trust that in that kind of
openhearted posture, Christ will help
you see and give you all that you need.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night uh Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, he held a
loaf of bread and he broke it and he
said, "Take it. Eat. This is my body.
it's broken for you. And then he held up
a cup of wine and he said, "Take this
and drink. This is my blood poured out
for you. Whenever you eat this bread,
whenever you drink this cup, remember
me."
So, as we uh come forward tonight,
that's the the truth that we're taking
in. It's this it's kind of beyond the
rational mind, you know, but it's a it's
bodily, it's experiential, it's a kind
of inner deeper knowing than we can
explain with uh with words. You ask me
to explain communion and what all is
happening. I don't know,
but I I trust I trust that somehow the
spirit's present, God's present to each
of us. So, the way we'll go about this
is we'll just start here at the front.
We'll go row by row and just forming a
line here in the middle. So, when one
row is done, the next one can, you know,
jump in. Um, just know that we practice
an open table. Uh, and so everyone here
is invited to participate regardless of
your, you know, exact like theology or
beliefs or whatever. something in you
wants to connect with Christ in this
way, then you're you're welcome to uh
participate. Uh just know the red is
wine, the white is grape juice. And
finally, you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like. Some people take
immediately, some like to come and kneel
here at the front. Um or you can return
to your seat, but uh however you want to
partake is is perfectly fine. So this is
the table, not of the church,
but of the Lord, and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who feel like
you failed. Come. Come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you and
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
We're going to close out tonight with a
song called The Kingdom is Yours. And um
it reminds me so much of uh the
biatitudes. And and the biatitudes
remind me so much of kind of what Brett
was saying. It's this kingdom where
things are flipped on their heads where
you don't really uh the norms are not
that the expected things are not what we
see in this kingdom of Jesus. It's it's
the unexpected. It's the poor and the
lowly among us who are raised up. It's
uh it's the meek. It's the peacemaker
um who is honored. Um so tonight we are
we are those that are brokenhearted and
also blessed. We are those who are
sometimes still and sometimes still
seen. Um we are sometimes small and yet
also honored. Um and we get to partake
in a kingdom um where we honor one
another not for the greatness among us
but for the little things. Um so if you
guys would stand with us and sing these
words tonight as we close.
Blessed are the ones who do not bury.
All the broken pieces of their heart.
Blessed are the tears of all the weery.
Pouring like a sky falling stars.
Blessed are the wounded ones in morning.
Brave enough to show the Lord their
scars.
>> Blessed all the hurts that are noted.
Open to the healing touch of God.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
>> Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
Blessed are the ones who walk in
kindness
even in the face of great abuse.
Blessed are the deeds that go unnoticed,
serving with unguarded gratitude.
Blessed are the ones who fight for
justice,
longing for the coming day of peace.
Blessed is the soul that thirsts for
rightousness,
welcoming the last, the lost, the least.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
Oh.
Blessed are the ones who suffer violence
and still have strength to love their
enemies.
Blessed is the faith of those who
persevere.
Though they fall, they never know
defeat.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more for this is not
the end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
>> Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
I can't. You guys, that song always gets
me every time.
It resonates as truth with me and I hope
it does for you too. Thank you so much
for being with us. You are so welcome
here and we are better for having you
here. That goes for you guys watching
online too.
If you're visiting with us tonight,
please take a moment to scan the QR code
that'll be up on the screens uh to fill
out our visitor card. You can also fill
one out on the table over there on your
way out. We just like to know that you
were here with us and have a chance to
thank you for that. Also, the QR code
will tell you everything that's going on
here as will our website, the tablet
tx.org.
Uh you can find out about our meetups,
which are our small groups. Uh you can
find out about the events going on, the
Sunday Unbound that's happening next sat
Sunday, and all of the the uh Holy Week
stuff that's coming up leading up to
Easter. Uh, also I'd like to ask Brett
to come up to share a message.
>> Um, I'll just be a second, but um, I
wanted to, well, basically 2025, that
was the our first year to ever be a
little bit in the red financially. And
so, uh, what I want to kind of throw it
out there to the community is to, um,
invite you to consider giving. And, uh,
many of you already do and that's that's
wonderful. Well, you know, maybe that's
been on kind of auto give for like years
and you're like, I wonder how much
that's for, you know, um maybe
prayerfully consider um what what you
might be able to give, you know, in this
year. Or maybe you've never uh haven't
given it in any way. And uh if you would
kind of open up your heart and just
yeah, consider what Christ might lead
you to uh to give to help support this
community. It is it's a it's a special
place and uh we want to, you know, see
it thrive for years to come. So, um just
yeah, invite you all to be uh kind of
praying and uh thinking on that this
week and you can do that through the QR
code or, you know, on the website
tabletx.org. Thanks.
All right. Lastly, I would love to send
you into your week with a benediction,
which is just a fancy way of saying a
blessing for the road. So feel free to
hold out your hands in a posture to
receive or just open your heart to these
words that I believe are true for each
and every one of you.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day. So, as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between, go filled with the assurance
that you are loved,
you are worthy, and you are accepted
just as you are. and go filled with
God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts of compassion,
grace, and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with this
week. Be blessed. We'll see you next
Sunday. Good night.
>> The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
The kingom is yours.
Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
>> Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
>> Hold on a little more. This is not the
end.
Hope is in the Lord. Keep your eyes on
him.
Let's
start.